the protestant reformation was to put it
bluntly not well received by the
catholic church it wasn't long after
people like martin luther and john
calvin launched their attacks against
the church that western europe was
bitterly divided over what the correct
christian practices were but in the east
sat the orthodox christian world created
from a previous falling out with rome
who must have had their own opinions of
what was going on so what were those
opinions how did the orthodox world
react to the protestant reformation so
as of martin luther's theses the primary
centre of orthodoxy was constantinople
which was under the ottoman empire and
itself oversaw two other major orthodox
centers kiev under the polish lithuanian
commonwealth and moscow run by the
moskovites and to all of them their
reaction was largely negative with some
caveats starting with constantinople
because the patriarch there was the
highest ranking person in the orthodox
world the reaction was largely one of
concern there was no love for rome in
the east but the reformation wasn't
initially about founding a new church
but about reforming the existing one
which to those in the east just meant
that they were still catholics just once
getting it all even more wrong which
meant any christian unity would be much
harder and also these heresies had a
tendency of spreading which was not
something they wanted in their own lands
but barring these initial thoughts there
wasn't much in the way of formal
communication between orthodox and
protestant christians for many decades
whilst the theological realms didn't at
first interact all too much this didn't
stop the political ones from doing so
and in moscow sar ivan iv better known
as ivan the best dad ever had both a
severe and optimistic response to
protestantism for him this heresy
weakened his catholic neighbours and
previously such schisms had led to civil
war meaning that for moscow it presented
an opportunity for westward expansion
personally though the tenets of
protestantism disgusted him and his
primary concern was these ideas
spreading into his realm the same way
that they had done in prussia and poland
lithuania and guess what they did
leading to several high-profile
prosecutions for what was then known as
frivolous thinking so back to church's
talking there was some optimism in the
late 16th century that the orthodox and
lutheran church could cooperate and in
the eyes of some even reunite and the
first step in this was seeing if the
doctrines were compatible and this was
done by sending the translated augsburg
confession to the orthodox church in
1575.
this was a list of 21 fundamental
pillars of the protestant faith sent to
the patriarch of constantinople and he
was not pleased with them he responded
that seven of these creeds were outright
heretical and so good luck in hell and
whilst the orthodox church agreed with
the rest of the articles lutherans were
doing them wrong at first the orthodox
church tried to push for cooperation
with the protestants but it wasn't
shocking to know that both sides were
pretty firm in their beliefs and despite
more communication by the end of the
16th century both denominations had
accepted that there would be no unity
between them and so the orthodox
reaction to that was the same as it was
for catholics they were just heretics
and for the protestants the feeling was
mutual
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly moneymaker mr wolf sky chappelle
jerry lamdin yn hockey marvin castle
jordan longley gareth turner rod d
martin bugley wiggily captain cydog
spencer lightfoot corso wolfe gustav
swan matthew shipley winston caywood
robert wetzel aaron the white marcus
arsenal maggie paxkowski anthony beckett
alex schwinn moe the mukwopa coppertone
spinning three plates ben ivinson
charles the first adam stalter and
scottish trekkie